tam şu anda şu anda bir durum
duyuyor musunuz Bir sürü sesin içinde
tam şu anda 11 milyar tane mesaj
gönderildi 4 trilyondan fazla mail
atıldı ve tam şu anda şu harcadığımız
süre içerisinde
207 bilgisayar oyunu
aplikasyonları yüklenmek üzere canlı
yayında Yani biz bu ana sındırdıklarımız
içerisine inanılmaz şeyleri yapıyoruz
dijital dünyada ve bu dijital dünyanın
içerisinde basit bir bireyin gelecekteki
bir başka avatara ve avatarlara
dönüştüğüne doğru yavaş yavaş yolculuk
yapacağız ama bu geçiş son yüz yıl
içerisinde o kadar inanılmaz şekilde
oldu ki insanoğlu bu değişimin nasıl
şekilleneceğini nasıl ilerleyeceğini
anlamaya çalışıyor bu yolculuğun başına
bakacak olursak Aslında telefonlara
dikkat etmemiz gerekli yani telefonların
yolculuğunda
derin yolculuğunda yıl
an oyunu telefonlarının melodilerini
değiştiren bireylerden
gardar'ın raporuna ve dünya devlerinin
raporuna göre yeni
evre uyumlu telefonlar alacağımız
cihazlar alacağımız bir dünyaya geçelim
Kurbağa Prens Masalı çok iyidir neden
Aslında birden fazla kurbağanın olduğu
bir gölde prensi bulmak için çok fazla
sayıda kurbağayı öpmeniz gerekir ve bu
teoriye göre bakacak olursak 2004
yılında herhangi
evinde bir bilgisayarı varken tableti
olmasına gerek yoktur Hatta yanında
taşıyabileceği bir cihazı olmasına gerek
yoktur demişti teknoloji devleri
Biz 40'lı Yıllara Geri dönersek
Amerika'daki halk oylamasında içinde
asansör sürücüsü olmayan bir asansöre
binmek kadar tehlikeli bir şey yoktur
demişti insanlar yani teknoloji ile
insanın İmtihanı inanılmaz şekilde
güncellenip değişiyor ve bu yolculuğun
son noktasında şu an Dünya üzerinde
bilinen fazla çipli yaşama geçmiş ve
bunu gönüllü olarak kabul etmiş insanlar
var ve Çiftliği yaşamın cep telefonu ile
yaşamdan daha kolay olduğunu
düşünüyorlar neden cep telefonunuzu
kaybederseniz Muhtemelen hayatınız kayar
cipinizi kaybetme ihtimaliniz yok ya da
cep telefonunuzla birlikte lavaboya da
girme alışkanlığınız varsa Muhtemelen
üzeri virüs ve bakterim kaynıyor ama
çipinizde böyle bir dert yok Bu bir
tercih meselesi Ama bu tercih
meselesinde Ben asla çiplenmem diye yani
insanın kendi anneannesine kendi
babaannesine televizyon algılamayan
büyüklerine bakması gerekir Çünkü bu
değişim yolculuğunun içerisine size ters
gelen şey çocuğunuzun normali olacak
tarif dünyadaki varlıklarla Bağ Kur
Maya çok Hatta bağımız öyle bir seviyeye
geldi ki fiziksel de dokunamayacağımız
dokun
mayız karşılamayacak olan bir varlığa
kıyafet alabiliriz ilk bebek giydirme
oyunu 2004 yılına aittir satın alma
Uygulama için satın almanın olduğu bebek
giydiririm oyun 2004 yılına aittir 2004
yılında 7 yaşında bu oyunu oynayan bir
çocuk an itibariyle 20 yaşının üzerinde
ve onun için bir başka alemde kendi
kimliğini oluşturan Avatar için şapka
gözlü kalmak Ben Sercan bir çanta almak
Bilmem nereden bilmem ne almak kadar
basit normal bir şey yok çünkü temel
ilke şu; Aslında geçmişinde olursanız
geleceğinde de olursunuz belli bir yaş
grubu bunların hepsini bilirler
klementin TRT Bunların hepsi TRT'de
yayınlandı Aslında hepsini birer Mete
Evren hikayesi vardır klementin yürüme
engellidir
ve hemoro sayesinde bir başka evrene
geçer ve bu geçtiği evrende fiziksel
dünyadaki engeli kalkar ortadan
Mete Evren ilişkilendirdiğiniz Facebook
yeni adıyla Meta fiziksel dünyada
yapamadıklarımızı yapacağız dedi
1985 yapımı bu Fransız filmde de aynı
şeyi anlatıldı ya da hemen yanındaki
lesmondes 1985 yılı yine TRT'de 90'lı
yıllarda gösterilmiş olan bir başka
çizgi film orada da çocukların başka
evrenlerde masallar dahil tarihler dahil
geçmiş ve gelecek dahil her şeyi
görebileceği anlatıldı insanoğlunun en
büyük hayali zaman yolculuğu bugün
İstanbul Sokaklarında dolaşıp 1800'lere
gidebiliyorsunuz Mete evrenlerde
ışınlanmak Mümkün çünkü ve bunu mümkün
hale getirirken daha da ileriye doğru
gidelim 90'ların başında şeker pembe
adıyla TRT'de cumartesi günleri
yayınlandı
ve son çizgi Filmimiz yine 90'ların
başında Magic Knight olarak geçiyor
sihirli Şövalyeler olarak çevrildi
3 tane lise öğrencisi orta son ya da
lise yalan olmasın bir başka evrene
gidiyorlar bu evrende fiziksel dünyada
yapamadıklarını yapıyorlar ama bir sorun
var
boyayı öğrendi birinci sezonun sonunda
öyleydi Çünkü bu Evrende bir nihai karar
vermeleri lazım ve bu verdikleri nihai
karar fiziksel dünyada %100 iyi anlaşır
ama bulundukları evrende de %100 doğru
ve bulundukları evrenin şartları da göre
karar veriyorlar fiziksel dünyaya
döndükleri zaman özledikleri yer Aslında
öteki Evren oluyor Dünya üzerinde Şu an
100'den fazla Mete Evren var sadece
Facebook'tan bahsetmiyoruz Facebook
sadece Adını değiştirdi Hatta Siz işin
içerisine Eğer riyal teknolojilerin yani
sanal gerçeklik geliştirilmiş gerçeklik
arttır
ılmış mikser dediğimiz karma gerçeklik
Neyi eklerseniz bu sayıyı 1000'leri
2000'lere çıkarmak da mümkün Yani tek
bir evrenden bahsetmiyoruz Multi dersten
bahsediyoruz birinde sosyalleştiğiniz
birinde eğitim aldığınız birinde eski
zamanda kaybettiğiniz bir yakınınızın
anılarını yaşadığınız Evrenler
Anılar önemlidir Çünkü birinin
analarında olursanız
alışkanlıklarında da olursunuz bugün
belli uygulamalara bağımlı olmamızın tek
sebebi Hatta bize nasıl yata yaptırım
yaparlarsa yapsınlar asla
bırakamamamızın tek sebebi
anılarımızda da yer almış olmaları
anılarımıza gidecek olursak döviz
Harikalar Diyarında da çok iyi bir Mete
Evren tasviri vardır Alice beyaz tavşanı
takip eder ve takip ettiği beyaz
tavşanla geçtiği evrende metafizik
kurallarına ihlal eder fizik kurallarını
hiç eder aynı zamanda
Deliliğin ve mantığın arasındaki ince
çizgide dolaşır lüks carrell dan sonra
1990 yılında Ahmet Kural altın dünyaları
isimli bir kitap yazar kendi
kitaplığımda ve bu kitapta Aslında Demet
isim kız çocuğunun ailesi ile çıktığı
Mini seyahatte bir başka evrene gitmesi
bu evrende istemi isimli bir çocukla
yeni geçtiği evrendeki Kanunlara uyum
sağlama süreci anlatılır hikayenin sonu
söylemeyeceğim belki ola ki kitabı
bulabilirsiniz ve son kitap
bu konuşulan ve met
e evreni müdahale edilen sınavı
yok edersiniz
geçmişin oluşturduğu boşlukları birisi
gelir ve doldurur Dolayısıyla kendi
kültürünüzdeki hikayeleri bilmiyorsanız
bu hikayelerin anlatıcılığını Mete
evrenlerde yapamazsanız başkasının
anlattığı hikayeleri dinlersiniz bugün
Google'a soran mesele için Google'da
Olmayan şey Asla yoktur
Google'ın sunduğu şeyde ve çok sıkça
sunduğu şeyde Muhtemelen doğrudur
Peki Google'da Olmayan şeyin olmadığı
bir dünyada sanat akımları kültürel
zenginlikler tarihi değerlerin olmadığı
Mete evrenlerde bireylerin
karşılaşacakları eğitim alacakları
öğrenecekleri kültür nasıl değişecek
fiziksel Ulus sınırlarından artık Mete
Ulus sınırlarına geçtik fiziksel Ulus
sınırlarınızı istediğiniz kadar
koruyabilirsiniz
meteolu sınırlarınızı asker dikemezsiniz
Siber güvenlik tehditlerine karşı yüksek
fairoğulları dikemezsiniz dikebilirsiniz
ama bir işe yaramaz
o evrende kültürünüz yoksa
otomatik olarak sınırlarınız zaten ihlal
edilmiş demektir çok bilindik bir şeyin
hastalığını yararsız herkes buradan Dem
vurur
insanoğlunun çok sıkça tekrarlanan bir
şeye karşı onaylama biyosu dediğimiz bir
şey vardır onaylanma teorisi çok sık
duyarsa doğru yanlış olan şey aslında
Onu doğru gelmeye başlar
[Müzik]
doğru kabul ettiğimiz ama aslında gerçek
olmayan şeyler var Maslow'un hiyerarşisi
bunlardan bir tanesi
[Müzik]
bunu da sayısal olarak ispatlamamıştır
bunu sadece bir görüş olarak öne sürdü
ama Mars'ta olurum ben bunu bir
çalışayım diyene kadar konu o kadar çok
ilgi gördü ki yayıldı ve bizim bir nevi
kurgu olan bir şey gerçeğimize dönüştü
işte
İçinde bulunduğumuz dünyadaki dijital
dünyadaki en büyük sorun bu fiziksel
dünyadaki bireyin Art niyetini biliyoruz
2020 yılında en çok yüz görüntünüzü ve
mimiklerinizi Paylaştığınız için yapay
zeka sayesinde bunu algılayabiliyoruz
ama dijitalde Bu mümkün değil 90'lı
yıllarda internet ilk yaygınlaşmaya
başlandığında bu karikatür işin rengini
değiştirdi ve bugün dijital dünyaya
geçtiğimizde artık karşımızdakinin ne
türlü nasıl bir varlık olduğunu
bilemeyeceğimiz gibi
ölmüş olan bir bireyin yeniden
modellenmiş versiyonu olup olmadığını da
bilemeyiz ki buradaki şirket bu hizmeti
veriyor yeterli derecede sosyal medya
neresi açarsanız sizi modellemek bizim
için hiç de zor değil aslında mesele şu
kimi takip ediyorsunuz
takip ettiğiniz şey ne varlık mı insan
mı bir Yapay Zeka mı Çünkü Bizler
geliştiriciler olarak örüntülerinize
bakıyoruz her pazartesi sinirli bir
tweet mi atmışsınız salı sendromunuz mu
var En sevdiğiniz siyasi görüş nedir
Bayram kutlamayı yılbaşı kutlamaktan
daha mı çok seversiniz bunlar için
sizinle konuşmamıza gerek yok bugün eve
gidin ve bir yıl boyunca sosyal medya
hareketlerinizi bir dış gözlemci olarak
bakın
Sık ve örüntü oluşturduğunuz davranışlar
sizi yakaladığımız noktada o örüntüyü
öğrendiğimiz noktada örüntüyü önce
besleriz Sonra bizi o kadar çok
alışırsınız ki yeni bir örüntü
verdiğimiz asla fark etmezsiniz ve bu
fark etmediğiniz dünyada filtreleme
balonu ya da Algoritma balonun içinde
yaşarsınız gerçek bir insanla
karşılaşabilirsiniz Mete evrende
dijitalde olduğu gibi Ve bu insan
şanslıysanız göründüğü gibi olan biri
olabilir ya da karşılaştığınız kişi
aslında
olduğu gibi görünen biri de olabilir
çünkü Mete evrende tasarlayacağınız
Avatar nasıl isterseniz o şekilde
görünecek gerçek bir insan olabilir ama
kimle olmayan
bize karar vermemiş olabilir bugün 13
yaş üstündeki her bireyin yaşadığı
sıkıntı bu aslında
büyük Devler geçtiğimiz senelerde
anlaşmaları olduğu sanatçılara Mete
evrende kadınsı erkek
erkekse kadın siyahi ise Beyaz olma
şartı getirdi ve Kaan'ın burada ne yazık
ki etkisiz kaldı bir bokla
karşılaşabilirsiniz sizden veri toplayan
öğrenmenizi destekleyen
sosyalleşmenizi sağlayan ya da sadece
sizden veri toplayan geçen sene en çok
Club House konuşuldu fakat Club hafıza
dikkat ettiyseniz isminin yanında rakam
var isminin altında da atasözü olan
bütün hesaplar bot hesaplardı ve sizinle
beraber
söylediklerinizle beraber anahtar
kelimeler konuşma biçiminiz ürettiğiniz
veri ve bu verileri kimleri
ilgilendirdiğinizi detaylı topladılar
Bir de otla sosyalleşebilirsiniz dünya
üzerindeki iki ülke hariç hiçbir kanun
veri Koruma Kanunu ölen bireyin veri
sahipliğini tanımaz Yok öyle bir şey
kişisel verinin sahibi olmanız için önce
hayatta olmalısınız
bu kadar veri paylaşıyorsunuz bu veriler
öldüğünüzde miras bırakılamadığı için
benim gibi araştırmacılara bu gibi
şirketlere bu verilerden yeniden sizi
modelleme şansı veriyorsunuz
hiçbir kanun Beni siz öldükten sonra
sizin bir dijital varlığınızı üretmeme
engellemiyor başarılı operasyonlar var
bir yapay zeka ile sosyalleşebilirsiniz
bugün Mete evreni hiç boşu boşuna
konuşmuyoruz çünkü Mete evrende fiziksel
dünyada toplayamadığımız her şeyi
toplayacağız ama bir sıkıntımız var
şu anda alternatif evrenleri çoklu
evrenlere konuştuğumuz bir dünyada
insanın ahlakıyla ilgili hala sıkıntı
var bu sene nftiler pazarından bir
tanesinde Mete köleler satışa çıktı ve
ne hikmetse hepsi siyahıydı Oysa 1662
yılındaki Vir
jinali kabul etmiştik siyahi bireylerin
köle olabileceğini söylemiştik
ihtiyacımız olan tek şey Şefkat herkesin
ihtiyacı olan tek şey Şefkat birbirimize
yapay zekaya ve karşımıza çıkan her
varlığa göstereceğimiz şefkat ve bu
şefkatin altına önce şüphe yatıyor
karşılaştığınız içerik gerçek mi
karşılaştığınız içerik doğru mu
Manipülasyon amaçlı üretilmiş 2020
yılının son çeyreğinde dünya genelinde
8.1 milyar sahte haber paylaşıldı
NATO Yaklaşık 5 yıldır
Bir ülkenin sosyal medya ya da dijitalde
akan verileri ile kendi yöneticilerine
kendi ekonomik dengelerini sağlayan
bireylere karşı kışkırtılmasını
çalışıyor 30 ülke ile beraber
primsonya senaryosu olarak
bulabilirsiniz eğitime ihtiyacınız var
faziletli olma ihtiyacımız var etik
Vicdan ve ahlaklı her zaman ihtiyaç var
Çünkü insan
bildiğimiz şekilde enerji üretilsin diye
temiz enerji üretilsin diye geliştirilen
nükleer Bir aracın nagazaki'ye
atabilecek kadar vicdanlı bir yaratık
bizim şefkate ihtiyacımız var Çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]